holy [ __ ] its markiplier again hell yeah
let me rub your nips
we're back playing player unknown I won
last game so this should be easy that's
fine
[Music]
[ __ ] Jesus Christ stop [ __ ] someone
landed and they went in the building
before I did oh [ __ ] they're here I'm
out I'm out oh [ __ ]
bye great this is the great start
there is ice time
Leroy Jenkins [ __ ] right here yeah oh
you go [ __ ] dude yes oh I'm so sorry
okay alright [ __ ] I thought these cars
we're real alright I always go like edge
of the city because then I know at least
where they won't be coming from most
likely hey that's night / oh yes never
got me a sniper I'll take that [ __ ] Domo
Domo Domo Domo that's pretty good
come on give me something some gas for
that ass gotta close the doors now I'm
not making that mistake again there we
go
I think the aks my favorite no [ __ ] sake
give me back my helmet come on come up
oh [ __ ] I need a backpack come on man I
hate being in buildings it [ __ ]
scares me
I need a backpack for [ __ ] sake throw
away some [ __ ] okay cool
yes thank you
the beginning is always so [ __ ] dead
unless like there we go nice Hey
some boots why not unless like you go in
the middle of all the [ __ ] you're just
gonna [ __ ] chill for a while most
likely so I think I saw a car in the
outskirts
I really want to just get a car because
guy to keep moving
there it is
that's my [ __ ] Volvo and nobody touch
it [ __ ] I don't like it running around
like this hey it makes me nervous Adachi
I don't know why I feel safer in a car
okay makes me feel
okay
jump whoa
excellent driving I'm the best driver
ever thank you very much
I wasn't realize now you can just hold
that [ __ ] all - look around I didn't
no one [ __ ] told me that
see if I can find anyone
somehow Schumacher running around here
so [ __ ] hard to see when you're
moving though
oh hell no
[Music]
let's follow him okay
oh sure hahaha what the [ __ ] were you
doing okay cool
Bobo everyone and the [ __ ] did his [ __ ]
go what the [ __ ] is a come on dude where
is his lunch box oh there it is nice
hell yeah I'll be taking this and this
okay doesn't have that much yeah I
prefer the AEK I still don't know what
ammo goes to what so I'll just [ __ ]
take whatever
get in get in get in get it oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh my help my [ __ ] help
J says Christ how am i alive get the
[ __ ] out of here Volvo I got a heal I
got a heal so [ __ ] I can't heal when
I Drive [ __ ] what idea I'm so [ __ ] one
shot and I'm dead
one little puff on my butt a fart could
kill me
getting [ __ ] out of here
I need a hit live man
okay here should be good lay down heal
up wait I got a med kit yeah hell yeah
hell yeah [ __ ] you for shooting me how
dare you shoot at my Volvo for Volvo
copy I don't [ __ ] know you know what
you know what you know what you're gonna
regret doing that [ __ ] yeah I mean he
must be still running this is so [ __ ]
stupid
I'm trying to see if I like if the
slender I don't know what the [ __ ] it's
called in English there's like anyone
behind
there is there he is that's what you
[ __ ] get [ __ ] hell yeah
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] give me a [ __ ] give me a
[ __ ] bandage military west hell yeah
I'll take that [ __ ] oh nice
okay okay
worth it worth it
so anyone else anyone else that was the
fury of the Volvo and af2 slam today
the comment will translate I don't know
what the [ __ ] to call it
you're not getting in this white circle
I'm the guardian
there is yeah Oh Oh does he see me he
deceives me the slalom slow up Baba
oh my god hell yeah I'm sorry dude I'm
really sorry
that's gotta suck for you man I get it
killed by Volvo oh [ __ ]
No - better okay I don't know [ __ ] it
let's just get out of here can you
imagine just bolo out of nowhere
oh [ __ ] someone what [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't shoot my car sweet ass oh [ __ ] I
missed [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do I do seriously what do I do
my car is fine my car is on [ __ ] fire
[ __ ] what do I do set in yeah yeah yeah
I hear you say okay okay okay oh yes
[ __ ] you hell yeah [ __ ] you for shooting
my car hey
[ __ ] after splinter
anyone else [ __ ] I'm scared there is a
car up there this might be incredibly
[ __ ] stupid but I'm gonna have to
abandon the Volvo I know it hurts my
soul
it hurts my berry essence of life it
hurts Who I am and what I believe in I
got two minutes should be fine
got a drive pretty far though I'm okay
painkillers would be nice this is gonna
hurt a little bit I'm just gonna call
you ball ball just for Sweden's sake I
know this is probably some Russian
[ __ ] Hardiman
if I win this whole thing just with the
car I'm gonna [ __ ] myself just with the
Volvo
and you found strategy
this video sponsored by Volvo by the way
full disclosure
oh I see someone
he's shooting that other car
I'm gonna pretend like I don't see him
just kidding I see you oh hell yeah five
just oh my god Volvo I don't think it's
safe
uh hell yeah yeah this is definitely a
good spot this is how you play player
unknown mountain goat style just as long
as no one sniped oh oh oh oh oh [ __ ]
we're gonna need a new strategy here
I'm gonna heal Oh [ __ ] bandages suck
he has to run
make it sneak up on him oh [ __ ] there
yes there yes yes run [ __ ] run
Wow
hell yeah oh my god
it's ridiculous you got fuck-boy that's
what you get that's what you're [ __ ]
get is nice freedom hater more like
freedom whatever got him oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] I wasn't paying attention
[ __ ] [ __ ] get out of here
gotta get out
oh [ __ ] another [ __ ] demon
[ __ ] that I'm on
it's literally right in this circle but
it's pretty up instead I'm [ __ ] a
[ __ ] well we're just gonna chill here
for a while everyone top of the mind
into yeah this is my new house this is
where I make videos now all right we're
heading out time to move again on the
road again then everybody's singing I'm
I'm going rolled again I don't know the
lyrics or the melody throw it again no
no not today
oh hey no nope stop nope
dare you stop
the [ __ ] is stopped shook stop stop
stop [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right this is where I hung out when
I won last time this is my spot although
I'm not going inside [ __ ] that [ __ ] this
is where I belong in the trash we're top
ten we're top ten everyone [ __ ] me man
why am I sitting okay all right
there's bound to be someone here yep the
answer is yes okay all right all right
all right all right I get it maybe not
the best idea to drive a vehicle here in
the mountain I got it
Julie noted it looks like it's about to
explode as well maybe you know what I'll
Park here thank you
come on Felix come on main you got this
[ __ ] I'm gonna make sure we're safe
okay the circle just got smaller
just like my butthole this is great I'm
gonna drink a Red Bull everyone I think
I've earned it hey you know what
double up it's caffeine time baby maybe
doing some chess okay it's me and seven
people come on six people left
I feel like if I get it if I get to the
top I don't think there's anyone behind
me I should have a pretty good spot
there's definitely someone up here come
up
Oh all right let's sneak up on him
[ __ ] is he [ __ ] I'm nervous now it's
five people come on where where oh no
lock no damn it it was a good run it was
really fun I enjoy that one I hope it
was fun for you anyway obviously I'm not
gonna win them all but if you enjoy
watching leave it like I really
appreciate all the positive comments on
the on this and I'm genuinely having
such a blast playing like I'm [ __ ]
it's an exciting game I really enjoy it
and I don't [ __ ] know [ __ ] this game
I'm uninstalling